el narco de narcos en manos de las
autoridades rafael caro quintero de 69
años uno de los más grandes capos de la
droga en méxico y ex líder del cártel de
guadalajara fue apresado durante una
operación conjunta entre la marina y la
fiscalía la captura sucedió nueve años
después de su salida de prisión desde
entonces se reincorpora el tráfico de
drogas desatando duras batallas
territoriales en el norte de mexico
quintero cumplió 28 años de una
sentencia de 40 por el asesinato de un
agente de la dea en
1985 por lo que el departamento de
justicia de ese país buscará su
extradición
el arresto de hoy es la culminación del
trabajo incansable de la dea y sus
socios mexicanos para llevar a caro
quintero ante la justicia por sus
presuntos delitos incluida la tortura y
ejecución del agente especial de la dea
enrique kiki camarena estaremos buscando
su extradición inmediata a los eeuu para
que pueda ser juzgado por estos crímenes
en el mismo sistema de justicia que la
gente especial camarena murió
defendiendo la secretaria de marina del
gobierno mexicano ofreció detalles de
cómo se produjo la captura en este con
texto se informa que citado objetivo fue
localizado entre matorrales por un
elemento canino de esta institución de
nombre max cuyo adiestramiento de
búsqueda y rescate permitió su ubicación
durante la década de los 70 caro
quintero fue uno de los principales
distribuidores de cocaína heroína y
marihuana hacia eeuu en el fugitivo más
buscado por la agencia antidrogas
estadounidense y su cabeza tenía precio
la dea ofrecía 20 millones de dólares
por información que diera con su captura